hello before this video begins I have
exciting announcement I'm partnering up
with the daylight that's right everyone
for those who don't know what deal is
it's a live streaming platform live
streaming is coming up in the future
that seems like a great idea Felix D
live is built of the lunar blockchain
they provide a disruptive solution for
the industry what does that mean let me
tell you D lives mission is to empower
creators but how you may ask through
their revolutionary reward system number
one they take no platform cut so
basically if you donate to a streamer or
if you subscribe to a streamer the
website itself usually takes a
percentage of that not on the line it
all goes to the Creator pretty cool
number two viewers as well can earn line
o points which is the currency simply by
engaging with the streamers pretty epic
number three is one that I really like
as well because users themselves get to
influence the shape of the platform
guide where its direction is going and
also get rewarded for it for having the
line of points personally I think it's
really cool to have a creator base
website actually putting creators first
so I'm really excited about the live and
I'm really excited to finally be
live-streaming again if you want to
check out the life you can download
their app in the description follow me
I'm gonna be live-streaming there soon
very frequently also my very first live
stream is gonna be pretty epic I'm gonna
become steal mr. beast entire formula
and donate to people live-streaming on
the lines no one's ever done that mr.
B's has not done it on D live so
basically I will donate between 10,000
and 50,000 dollars and this money will
come from you guys basically just by
following other people other streamers
you are contributing to this pool of
money that will go to the people in
streaming it doesn't require you to
actually spend any money it just
requires you to follow someone on the
website so go check out the live go
follow some streamers and let's get this
bread gamers they give you live response
during this video and I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
YouTube's favorite show name review zip
you spilled everywhere god damn it so
annoying okay I've seen this video a few
weeks ago and it was like yeah that's
annoying it's not really funny either it
just makes me uncomfortable but now it's
a meme so I'm gonna have to kill it
you're gonna die you're right it is that
is the tea you did it honestly bro I
hate this stupid effing video and it get
worse every time I see it kind of Normie
freaking garbage is this I don't
understand how a [ __ ] can be so
annoying and that's the tea why why did
this have to become a meme up it I say
stop oh god what is this Oh God
I made up for it why don't you mock up
why don't you mock up of course of
course
thank you Chinese mean mom can we have
her recreate all the memes from now on
I get it I get it okay you think you're
funny with your little edit oh I'll put
Minecraft on this or I'll put Jojo on
this oh I'll put that's all I got I
understand I get it now why would you -
stop stop yeah I'm going to take this
away from you know what's the T what is
the T so speak you can tell me what's
the T it just annoys me why does it
annoy me so much is it hitting the
screen it's that are annoying
condescending tone is it that I don't
know maybe old things combined that's
been at least two good memes out of this
so far so at least you know I don't hate
it too much but this meme gets of course
a - good - that's bad - what a pen
that's a bad rating by the way I just
want to be clear I don't like this mean
in case it's not obvious already I hate
this me I hate everyone about it I don't
like it
I wanna die it makes me there has
however been some good means for example
that we need a poo tuxedo mean some
would say Burger King but we the finer
people would say the monarch of Hamburg
excellent name I'm thirsty no I'm hunger
for wet Jesus Christ come creme Dilip in
Jesus Christ here present absent Oh
absolute got it
good joke this is literally I know
people it gets tiring to point out how
all the memes are just same form line
they're slightly different or iteration
this is clearly that oh you know the
brain memes are whatever gif or Jif
whichever will it be sit the 7/7 okay
see it continues as well it's the exact
same but it's so funny let's keep going
I'm sorry for your loss
Oh oh my god yes
that is amazing what an amazing
crossover
at that absolutely beautiful data data
what do you say data looking at this
data looking at this data I don't care
PewDiePie pewdie Felix Kjellberg
marzia's boyfriend I mean that's pretty
clever condom dick armor creme de la
panache $1,000 or one comma zero zero
zero you plebeian normies would never be
able to be this educated to post these
type of memes you're gonna be the top
bar all your life aren't you
there's a hot girl behind you watch your
six being into fat girls having six
heads for the fake the heads the curse
Cygnus is really what makes this meme
stand out and I think that's what makes
it special if you do this mean without
the cursive font then don't bother okay
don't waste my time
oh my god yes what everyone draw these
like everyone it's a universal s this s
transcends time and space kids
everywhere aliens or whatever they will
all draw the s like this I work at
McDonald's I have a part-time job in
fast food I handle transactions through
a multi-billion dollar company and an
industry on daily basis and help provide
around 2 billion to the US economy each
year also I work at McDonald's anal
sexing but fricking peepee in the poopoo
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory I
wonder when these new memes comes out if
people just look at the old format and
be like ok this joke put it there ok got
it
now off vote everyone why FX
I've now you say that in English
individuals who do not require the first
panel to understand this no one
basically no one understand this but me
that's right and you everyone who's
watching this of course I'm actually
like on this video while you're ranted
I'm about to end this means yeah exactly
that's the me that's to me
normal tanks Carson text 3d text shaky
takes shaky 3d lgbtq oh there they are
nothing will ever beat shaky three
LGBTQ text next name everyone duolingo
is becoming a meme and whenever there's
accompany me my there's always in my
back of my mind going well did they
plant this we think playing this out
it's like those mafia City memes do they
do they even purpose did they create
these three animations just to become a
meme well do a lingo for some reason
isn't mean I thinks I've actually called
this out like in a video didn't eat have
you ever had to do a lingo app where
they always ask you it's language right
languages the language if you download
duolingo and you don't use it you'll
keep getting notifications of your phone
be like have you done your exercises
have you done it you are a better bed
make your exercises well now duolingo
you what duolingo is tired of you not
doing your exercises
do you goddamn exercises neglect your
lingo act he will kill you did you learn
a new language SC signora duolingo Olli
what did it cost math Amelia do Senor
duolingo only time for Japanese how to
save your family
Anna Tana Kazoku oh so cool oh it seems
you haven't practice your language
listen for two days it's duolingo Jenny
don't forget your daily French lessons
or you die oh my god matter the neg can
I say Megiddo say Stute say K to have
the ITA
may we and duolingo arm Jesus in Christ
beg for your life in Spanish the
duolingo bird when I haven't been acted
for two days next main this duolingo
meme gets up by yeah that's a rating
what a random words are saved just like
that Shaq Shaq went and ate some spicy
chicken wings which is the pinnacle of
comedy and it needs to be mean at least
you know this name I can appreciate you
two making edits out of instead of that
goddamn yeah
[Music]
obligated minecraft edit at this point
what else did we got in ahead we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that grammar into a deep dive we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that grammar into a deep
dive
how spicy was that wing Jesus Christ
segment on our show called explain that
grammar it would pretty good mean format
I don't know what to tell you when you
randomly turn on your phone and it's a
69 20 and Wednesday my dudes quiet kid
wrote someone literally everyone goes
pulls out a single stick of gum from my
pocket every single student around me no
it's my god god damn it
thank you guys for watching name review
the greatest show on the goddamn planet
support the show by checking out the
epic merch and I'll see you bro skis on
the brofist on a hundred male baby let's
freakin go tubers simulator it's now so
relevant that it's got a brand new
minigame cranium drop the crane and get
fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game and you say
there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys like